- I'm Chris Cotton, and I'm
here at Comedy Central's
Roast of Bruce Willis,
and I have one question:
Whachu talkin' 'bout, Willis?
Willis?
- Willis?
- Oh, I see what you
did there and I like it.
(Hip-Hop music)
- So we wanna ask you a couple
trivia questions real quick.
All right?
- Okay, do any of
them consist of:
"Am I gonna sleep
with Bruce Willis?"?
- In what year did Bruce
Willis first appear
fully bald in a film?
- I don't know.
I'm gonna go with the
year I was born, 1989.
- Okay, 2007.
- Oh, I'm sorry, Bruce.
- Exactly, I think.
- The roast starts now.
(laughing)
- If Bruce Willis was an
animal, what would he be?
- I would say he
would be a hyena.
Female hyenas have
pseudo-penises, which
are about 15 to 16
inches long, and that's
what I envision from Bruce.
- How you doing, Jeff?
- Good. Call me Kim Jeff Un.
- Kim Jeff Un?
- AKA the ultimate
villain, the roast master.
I'm coming for you Bruce Willis.
(laughing)
The ultimate hero's gonna meet
the ultimate villain today.
And by the way, I loved
you as the cop in Die Hard.
- Listen man, I
try to do my best.
I kept slim, I'm working out
a lot, you know what I mean?
- You look great.
(Hip-Hop music)
- In which movie did Bruce
Willis show his willy?
- I don't know.
- You don't know?
- No, why don't I know this?
- In The Color of Money.
- The Color of Night.
- When would this
movie come out?
- It came out a while back.
- Did you know Bruce
Willis' character was dead
in Sixth Sense when
you first watched it?
- No.
- No, I was like seven,
I didn't think ahead.
- Spoiler alert, man.
You just ruined the movie
for a whole generation
of people that could've
enjoyed The Sixth Sense.
- He was dead in this one.
- And now it's ruined.
- Did you know
though, first watch?
- No, I didn't know.
Nobody knows, that's
why you ruined it.
(Hip-Hop music)
- Here's a quote.
- Okay.
- Let me know what this is from.
- "Zed's dead,
baby, Zed's dead."
- That would be Pulp Fiction.
- Pulp Fiction.
- I don't know how he
got it, Pulp Fiction.
- "I'm a world class
assassin, (beep) yeah.
How do you think I found out?"
- The Sixth Sense.
- No, he wasn't an assassin
in The Sixth Sense,
he was a psychologist.
- Lucky Number Slevin.
- My sister was in that.
- [Chris] That's good.
- She was in the sex scene.
- [Chris] I love that
movie, good movie.
All right.
Police man asked, "Are you
classified as a human?"
Willis responds, "Negative.
I am a meat popsicle."
- That is from, actually,
when he appeared on Friends.
(laughing)
That's what he said
to Jennifer Anniston.
- Actually it was from Fifth
Element, but thank you.
- Not familiar.
- What was Bruce Willis'
high school nickname?
- Daddy.
- Daddy?
- Boy, Bruce Willis'
nickname in high school.
I don't know.
(mumbling)
- Buck Buck.
- This is the creepiest thing
ever, but the Gimp got it.
For all the points in the
world, give it up, Buck Buck.
Thank you Gimp.
- Way to go Gimp.
- Thank you Gimp. Thank you
all, we'll see you all inside.
And that was just Whachu
talkin' bout Willis?
- Love you, happy
Roast Day everybody.